bonjour à tous Bienvenue c'est l'heure
de Parlement Hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver avec Katia guilder bonjour
Katia bonjour Mickaël de 45 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actu politique et
parlementaire cette semaine beaucoup
d'actualités avec une réforme une manif
et un décret la réforme du collège
devrait voir le jour plus vite que prévu
l'exécutif a décidé d'accélérer la
droite s'est emparée du sujet et cherche
toujours des voies possibles pour faire
parage à cette réforme et on parlera de
la réforme du droit d'asile examiné au
Sénat la droite à durcit le texte contre
la vie du gouvernement un débat qui
tombe en pleine polémique en France sur
les quotas de migrants souhaités par
l'Union européenne vous le savez la
droite organisera des primaires ouvertes
pour trouver son candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 une première pour
ce mouvement un processus venu des
États-Unis qui est devenu un passage
obligé en France l'histoire des
primaires c'est notre plus de l'hebdo et
cette semaine nous accueillons Thierry
Soler bonjour vous êtes député
UMP de Boulogne-Billancourt dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et vous êtes notamment
chargé de l'organisation des primaires
au sein de votre c'est parti pour
l'élection 2017 avant de vous interroger
sur l'actualité riche de cette semaine
je vous propose d'écouter notre
micro-trottoir sauf que pense de vous
certains de vos collègues écoutez
moi je crois qu'il porte bien son nom il
rayonne c'est un garçon qui rayonne qui
rayonne en politique parce qu'il a une
fraîcheur extraordinaire il a
un esprit très d'ouverture
il est toujours sur le pont c'est
quelqu'un qui s'engage qui bouge sa
chemise pour l'unité de notre formation
politique on le voit à travers ses
responsabilités sur les primaires il a
réussi quelque chose de très bien c'est
un homme abordable sympathique ouvert et
très intelligent je suis pas d'accord
avec tout sur lui avec ce qu'il pense
mais je pense que c'est un apport
certain du renouvellement de l'assemblée
une question par rapport
au Parlement Hebdo cette semaine vous
trouvez qu'il prend un peu trop de place
un peu trop médiatique
il y a des phases dans la vie publique
on l'a chargé de préparer la charte des
primaires
comme c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent
malin il a vu que c'était une
opportunité médiatique et c'est tant
mieux pour lui bon il y a des phases et
puis c'est pas mal de temps en temps
d'avoir des têtes nouvelles donc c'est
bon je trouve que trop de place non vous
savez il y a des phases hein dans 3 mois
vous me direz pour un autre est-ce que
vous trouvez pas que un tel ou une telle
prend trop de place et c'est faire tout
ce qui a pris n'est plus à prendre
vous reconnaissez votre portrait vous
êtes celui qui qui monte malin
intelligent vous êtes aussi
à mes électeurs comme chaque député donc
j'essaye de me comporter dignement et de
faire ce que je crois être bien et puis
après dans ma famille politique qui a
connu pendant deux ans de 2012 à 2014
après la défaite présidentielle beaucoup
de turbulences j'essaye au côté Bruno Le
Maire et avec toute l'équipe de l'UMP de
voilà de mettre un peu de méthode parce
que je pense que la méthode en politique
ça permet d'éviter beaucoup de bêtises
il y a des compétitions politiques c'est
naturel des consubstantiel même à la
politique mais vous jouez collectif bien
sûr d'abord moi je n'ai pas de haine je
vous le dis aussi clairement que je le
pense il y a de la haine parfois entre
certaines personnes moi j'ai énormément
de respect pour Nicolas Sarkozy pour un
AJP pour François Fillon pour viager
Bertrand pour Bruno Le Maire mais bien
sûr ils sont tous différents on est tous
dans la même idéologie politique on a
tous des ils ont tous des tempéraments
et des caractères différents mais il y a
j'ai aucun problème avec personne après
le moment venu ce qu'il faut et c'est ce
qu'on a mis en oeuvre on fera une
primaire et on choisira celle ou celui
qui nous permettra collectivement de
voilà de nous en sortir pas pour l'UMP
pour le pays parce que c'est ça qui
compte le plus alors la première bien
évidemment on va y venir un peu plus
tard dans l'émission on va passer par le
lundi c'est le premier jour de la
semaine et on se penche sur le droit de
la ville au Sénat
discussion examinée au Sénat ce lundi se
débat tombe en pleine polémique sur les
propositions de l'Union européenne qui
invitent les États membres à mettre en
place des quotas de migrants les
explications de Flora sauvage faut-il
instaurer des quotas migratoires dans
l'Union comme le suggère la Commission
européenne au Sénat le débat s'est
invité dans l'hémicycle lors de l'examen
de la réforme du droit d'asile est-ce
que on peut savoir clairement ce que
sera ou ce qu'est la position de la
France par rapport à la demande
européenne oui ou non la France
va-t-elle accepter la définition de
quotas européen prenant en compte les
efforts de généralisés après la
Grande-Bretagne la Hongrie et la Pologne
la France s'oppose au quota pour
l'accueil des réfugiés pour le
gouvernement la France a déjà fait
beaucoup d'efforts nous nous souhaitons
que ces demandeurs d'asile soir répartis
entre pays de l'Union européenne en
tenant compte des efforts déjà fait par
ces pays en matière d'accueil de
demandeurs d'asile et la notion de quota
pour les demandeurs d'asile n'a pas de
sens puisqu'à partir du moment où ce
sont des critères qui préside à leur
accueil l'utilisation du concept de
cotta n'a pas de sens qui trouvent
pourtant des défenseurs sur les bancs de
la gauche du Sénat vous ne pouvez pas
faire du talmudisme en faisant la
différence entre quota et répartition la
différence n'est pas tout à fait claire
là on fait vraiment un peu de on fait de
la rhétorique pour noyer le poisson la
question des quotas sera abordée lors du
prochain sommet européen le 30 juin
l'année dernière 626000 personnes ont
demandé l'asile en Europe soit une
augmentation de plus de 44% par rapport
à 2013
quota clé de répartition il y a un peu
de flou dans les mois employés alors
justement Manuel Valls lui est revenu
sur ses propos et a tenter de clarifier
ses positions devant la représentation
nationale écoutez il faut aussi éviter
les amalgames notamment entre le droit
d'asile et l'immigration irrégulière le
droit d'asile c'est un droit accordé à
partir de critères par conséquent par
définition le nombre de ces
bénéficiaires ne peut faire l'objet de
quota ça serait d'ailleurs une faute
morale éthique que d'aller dans cette
voie
Thierry solaire Bernard Cazeneuve estime
énorme de répartir la charge des
demandeurs d'asile entre les pays
européens Manuel Valls lui dit qu'il ne
veut pas de quota est-ce que pour vous
il y a un double langage un pour
Bruxelles et un pour les électeurs
français de toute évidence il y a un
grand flou dans la politique que conduit
la France sur ces sujets
ou malheureusement on comprend qu'ils
ont pas une vision clairement de savoir
qu'est-ce que la France va faire dans
ces sujets là d'abord Kota répartition
enfin pas bon si on dit que chaque pays
européen comme le dit Bernard cazen va
prendre une partie bah je vois pas de
différence avec un système de personnes
il faut arrêter avec les migration de ne
pas poser l'équation de l'immigration la
problématique de l'immigration elle est
multiforme il y a le droit d'asile le
droit d'asile c'est un immense sujet ou
aujourd'hui c'est tellement long
tellement il puisse avoir une réponse
administrative qu'en fait il arrive en
France il est le demandeur d'asile il
arrive avec sa famille puis ça dure 2
ans puis au bout de deux ans de toute
façon il sait ses enfants sont
scolarisés
qui s'est mis dans la société française
et en vrai il est pas expulsé ne pas
juger ne pas rendre justice et une
manière de la rendre et donc nous on
demande une réforme claire du droit
d'asile pour que ça soit rapidement
étudié quand six mois avec une voix
d'appel possible on puisse faire cela
mais qu'on arrête de dévoyer la
procédure de droit de vie deuxièmement
il y a le sujet de cette vague
d'immigration qui arrive du continent
africain qui est on le voit tous ah bah
j'ai par des conflits par plein de mots
l'immigration d'ailleurs africaine elle
est surtout intra-africaine il faut en
avoir conscience et surtout des
mouvements des migration énorme entre
les différents pays africains est-ce que
vous avez proposé parce que si bien
compris à l'UMP va y avoir des des
thématiques qui vont arriver notamment
l'immigration va arriver aussi très vite
qu'est-ce que vous allez proposer de
plus il faut qu'on ait ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement moi je
vais vous dire ce que j'attends de ma
famille politique et des différents
candidats le moment venu à la primaire
c'est qu'il n'est pas des facilités en
proposant des surenchères non crédibles
mais qui propose des choses qui soient
efficaces et que derrière l'état puisse
le mettre en oeuvre ça sert à rien de
faire des grandes propositions qui ne
sont pas crédibles ce que j'attends on
se rend compte de la situation la
situation spécifique des migrants en
Méditerranée sa transit énormément il
transit énormément par la Libye on le
voit bien donc ça pose un immense
problème sur ce sujet et donc moi je
crois que l'Union européenne qui
n'existe pas suffisamment sur beaucoup
de sujets elle doit exister sur ce sujet
là pour le coup en mutualisant des
moyens pour intervenir sur place pour
inviter pour empêcher les passeurs de
faire venir ces êtres humains qui
essaient de la traite d'êtres humains et
à traverser la Mini et on passe à cette
question parce que on a beaucoup entendu
parler vous savez d'une intervention
vous seriez pour une intervention en
Libye je crois qu'on ne pourra pas faire
l'économie à un moment ou un autre d'une
intervention en Libye parce
qu'aujourd'hui depuis la fin la chute du
régime de Kadhafi que je ne regarde pas
du tout que je pense qui était bien sûr
utile maintenant tout de suite je sais
pas je ne suis pas stratège militaire je
vous dis juste je ne vois pas comment et
j'entends Hubert-Félix ma main gauche
qui est une voix qui m'importe toujours
considérer la même chose on ne pourra
pas faire l'économie d'intervenir là-bas
c'est l'endroit où se développe le
terrorisme et notamment ce trafic d'être
humain
Europe et est tenu beaucoup par des
organisations terroristes et ça c'est un
une menace terrible pour la France et
pour l'Europe vous dites que l'Union
européenne doit se mêler de ces
questions mais en même temps vous dites
que sur l'asile sur les quotas il n'en
faut pas il faut que ça reste du domaine
de la souveraineté nationale bien sûr
qu'est-ce qui est de ressorts de l'Union
européenne
on compte mutualise des politiques parce
que la France ne peut pas seul qu'elle
fait au Mali en Centrafrique il y a des
quasiment seule à faire cela c'est pas
possible qu'il y a un seul pays fasse
tout que l'Europe que l'Union européenne
mutualise les moyens de tous les États
membres qui veulent s'engager pour avoir
une politique efficace
c'est les États qui l'ont à la voir et
on n'a pas à la Commission européenne
n'a pas de légitimité démocratique à
dire à la France comme à l'Allemagne
comme à d'autres qu'il faut prendre x
contingent de migrants
plus franco-françaises avec les
professeurs qui sont dans la rue et
cette grande réforme du collège et c'est
polémique
le gouvernement l'a dit il tiendra bon
face à la rue et les profs étaient en
grève ce mardi Manuel Valls lui soutient
sa ministre de l'éducation nationale il
a même décidé d'accélérer puisque la
réforme a été publiée par décret au
Journal officiel Marion Lefa Becker vous
explique tout ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine
je vous demande le gouvernement voulait
aller vite ces choses faites avec la
publication ce matin au Journal Officiel
du décret d'application de la réforme du
collège au lendemain de la manifestation
des enseignants et la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale lassume la
publication de ce décret va permettre
désormais que nous discutions des
modalités de mise en œuvre de la réforme
et donc je vous le dis ici chacune de
ces inquiétudes sera levée d'où ce
calendrier que j'assume et que je
maintiens nous devons avancer si nous
voulons que cette réforme entre en
vigueur à la rentrée 2016 elle le fera
dans l'intérêt des enfants mais
l'opposition dénonce un passage en force
publier ce décret cette nuit est un acte
politique brutal vous le paierez cher
monsieur le Premier ministre nous vous
demandons l'abrogation de ce décret et
la tenue dans les plus beaux rêves
délais d'un véritable débat démocratique
ici dans l'hémisme Jacob oui nous
voulons réformer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons des idées avec le
chef de l'État et avec la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale de publier ce
décret parce qu'il faut aller vite ce
gouvernement est déterminé à réformer
nous continuerons sur ce sujet là et
surtout les autres parce que c'est de
l'intérêt des Français la détermination
du gouvernement n'apaise pas la colère
de l'opposition bien au contraire on le
fait de publier des décrets au lendemain
de la manif on a vraiment le sentiment
que le gouvernement fait un bras
d'honneur aux manifestants je trouve que
cela tient de la provocation et cela
montre que Manuel Valls accorde plus
importance à la préparation du congrès
du Parti socialiste dans quelques jours
plutôt qu'à l'avenir de nos enfants
François Bayrou le président du MoDem
appelle la la manifestation nationale
j'en sais rien si on doit défiler pas
tout à fait notre culture ça nous aura
pas échappé moi j'ai le sentiment que le
débat il doit avoir lieu ici derrière
nous et pas dans la rue certains
syndicats et réfléchissent à de
nouvelles actions comme le snalk il
appelle au blocage des épreuves du
brevet des collèges
on a bien vu que la droite c'est
fortement mobilisé sur cette question et
notamment Bruno Le Maire un peu en chef
de fil mais on a quand même le sentiment
que vous avez été un peu pris de cours
par le gouvernement
c'est cette réforme du collège c'est un
peu vous aussi mais non mais moi ça
m'intéresse peu ça ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le fond le gouvernement alors que
il annonce vouloir tendre la main être
favorable à un débat qui a eu lieu hier
soir entre Belkacem et Bruno Le Maire à
la télévision et à la radio
publient des crèmes évidemment le jour
même de la manif typiquement c'est le
genre de de décision qui radicalise tous
les opposants moi je me crois
gauche-droite confondu qu'on ne peut
plus gouverner comme ça c'est il s'agit
pas de perdre du temps il s'agit pas
dans de faire des commissions tous les
jours pour ne rien faire c'est légitime
que le gouvernement veille décider mais
par contre il faut avoir une
concertation un débat public ne par
traiter les intellectuels de pseudo
intellectuels écoutez ce qu'a dit à
l'opposition et après le gouvernement
propose un texte et le Parlement sans
saisie
bien sûr par une loi l'assemblée on
légifère sur des choses parfois qui nous
paraissent un peu de second hein ordre
l'avenir de tous les collégiens et donc
de toute une classe d'âge et donc c'est
me semble-t-il bien sûr l'endroit où le
Parlement ou le débat doit avoir lieu en
premier chef il y a eu beaucoup de
réformes du collège beaucoup beaucoup de
contestations etc et finalement on voit
que le niveau est en baisse c'est
dernière est une internationale qui le
constate le niveau est en baisse
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas ce qui ne va pas
c'est que après 68 on a fait le choix
collectivement la gauche et la droite de
mettre toute une classe d'âge au
baccalauréat c'était le dogme le Graal
absolu au nom de l'égalité il fallait
que tout le monde laisse le bac et en
faisant cela on a dégradé tous les
métiers de la main toute cette
intelligence de la main que beaucoup de
Français avec beaucoup de jeunes ont en
eux on en voit tout le monde au max ceux
qui ont en capacité de l'avoir long ceux
qui ont du mal arrive en fin de cycle un
peu épuisé et puis derrière il y a pas
de formation réelle et vous vous
retrouvez en France avec un constat 25%
des jeunes au chômage alors que quand
vous allez à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de chez nous en Suisse 5% des
jeunes Suisses au chômage 70% en
apprentissage c'est-à-dire la vraie
apprentissage d'un métier regardez
l'initiative de Xavier Niel qui est
absolument très intéressante à observer
sur le numérique le grand patron
français qui a créé cet université
privée gratuite qui permet en fait
d'apprendre le code le codage on va dire
informatique il prend des gamins il se
fige de savoir s'ils ont eu le BAC le
brevet quelle formation il en rapporte
une formation qui correspond à une
qualification qui derrière des Bouchra
sur un métier quand vous êtes passé par
là vous avez pas de problème pour votre
avenir vous gagnez bien votre vie et
qu'est-ce qui m'intéresse moi pardon 2
secondes encore sur le sujet
c'est que plutôt que d'avoir ce dogme de
100% une caisse d'ajoba c'est d'avoir
100% du cash dans l'emploi et donc pour
ça il nous faut deux choses un revoir le
système éducatif le primaire c'est
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux le
collège ça doit faire deux choses hein
l'apprentissage de la langue française
de la grammaire des mathématiques de
l'histoire parce qu'on fabrique des
citoyens aussi l'apprentissage du
soclement du socle commun de la nation
l'histoire de notre pays aussi il est
valeurs de notre pays et puis à côté de
ça il faut donner dès le plus jeune âge
des enseignements optionnels qui
permettront à plein gamins qui en vrai
ont décroché sur un plan scolaire dès la
sixième de s'en sortir parce qu'ils
seront valorisés parce qu'ils réussiront
quelque chose et puis après s'il trouve
il réussissent dans le codage dès la 5e
et ben c'est vous la retrouverez à 25
ans ils ont déjà noté
le débat entre Bruno Le Maire et Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem on comprend que la
cible c'est la ministre mais non là-bas
il y a aucune attaque personnelle et je
vais vous dire précisément ce que
Nicolas Sarkozy a dit quand il a voulu
comparer les deux c'est que c'est la
même méthode sur la loi sur le mariage
pour tous que de la loi sur l'école
c'est des sujets qui intéressent tous
les Français c'est les sujets sur
laquelle il faut écouter ce que dit
l'opposition est-ce que disent les
Français et c'est les sujets sur
lesquels le président de la République
est le premier ministre disent circuler
il n'y a rien à voir au moment de la
manif pour tous quoi qu'on pense du fond
il y a eu près d'un million de gens dans
la rue on a même pas reçu représentant
de la manifestation alors qu'on reçoit
n'est pas une team mais non pas du tout
il y a aucune attaque de personnes il y
a juste le fait que dans la méthode
Parti socialiste mais oui mais parce
qu'il préfère parler de ça que parler du
fond ça les intéresse pas de parler du
fond ce qui les intéresse surtout c'est
ce culte en permanence de la
stigmatisation pour essayer de ne pas
regarder les vrais sujets il y a un
autre sujet qui suit beaucoup de clivage
un sujet de société sensible qui revient
dans le débat la gestation pour autrui
le tribunal de Nantes a autorisé cette
semaine l'instruction à l'état civil de
trois enfants nés de mère porteuse à
l'étranger la Cour de cassation doit se
prononcer sur cette décision explication
de Valérie Brochard
mercredi dernier le tribunal de grande
instance de Nantes s'est prononcé en
faveur de l'inscription à l'état civil
français de trois enfants nés de mère
porteuse en Russie une décision qui
réveille le débat sur la gestation pour
autrui d'un côté vous condamnez la GPA
et de l'autre vous incitez à cette
pratique en facilitant l'accueil des
enfants
issus de GPA à l'étranger nous sommes
dans un pays où nous veillons à protéger
les enfants madame il s'agit d'enfance
et en os d'enfants qui vont à l'école
d'enfants qui effectivement sont aussi
doués que les autres pour agacer les
enseignants pour énerver leurs parents
mais d'enfants de ce pays d'enfants de
la République et ses enfants là quoi que
vous disiez nous allons les protéger
madame
jusqu'ici la Cour de cassation a
toujours rejeté la reconnaissance
d'enfants nés de mère porteuse à
l'étranger mais la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme estime que la France
ne peut porter atteinte à l'identité des
enfants en refusant de les reconnaître
sans règle juridique évidente le parquet
de Nantes a préféré faire appel et se
retourne aujourd'hui vers le
gouvernement très embarrassé qui nous
est posée j'ai pas là de réponse
définitive parce que comme je suis
porte-parole du gouvernement je respecte
la parole collective du gouvernement il
y a pas eu d'expression en particulier
de la part des ministres qui sont
concernés par le sujet sur cette
question et c'est un sujet qui a suscité
de l'actualité va continuer à le faire
et là-dessus il va falloir effectivement
qu'on ait une position les opposants à
la légalisation de la GPA accuse le
gouvernement d'hypocrisie et s'organise
déjà j'ai déposé une proposition de loi
qui a été signée par une plus d'une
cinquantaine de parlementaires et qui
j'espère fera l'objet d'un examen dans
une niche ma proposition de loi d'abord
rappelle une chose c'est le principe de
territorialité c'est à dire que ce qui
est interdit en France ne peut pas être
permis à l'étranger et ensuite je
souhaite que ce soit un délit spécial
dans notre droit dans l'attente d'une
position claire du gouvernement la
circulaire Taubira est toujours en
vigueur et facilite depuis janvier 2013
l'obtention de certificats de
nationalité pour les enfants de père
français né de mère porteuse à
l'étranger le débat ne fait que
commencer le débat ne fait que commencer
sur un sujet très complexe qui est
embarrasse on le voit le gouvernement
vous vous dites quoi que qu'est-ce que
quel statut vous donner à ces enfants
que la ministre Taubira veut protéger
quel statut vous donner à ses enfants
fantômes bon d'abord c'est un sujet très
compliqué sur laquelle il faut
travailler avant de s'exprimer c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire moi je vais
vous dire ce que je pense sur ce sujet
là le désir d'enfant c'est très légitime
moi j'en ai quatre j'ai cette chance là
je comprends qu'un homme et une femme
qu'un homme qu'une femme et envie
d'avoir un enfant et qu'on peut pas en
avoir c'est compliqué 2 qu'est-ce que
c'est la GPA c'est les mères porteuses
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une mère porteuse
on va nous expliquer expliqué que
parfois c'est un système qui vous permet
parce que vous avez la femme qui
consentante elle a très envie c'est pas
vrai pardon regardez dans la vérité en
face la mère porteuse c'est toujours la
même chose c'est une femme pauvre qui
prend l'argent et qui loue son corps en
échange de prendre de l'argent est-ce
que en France on trouve ça moral non
mais personne
justement en fait je vais essayer de
vous faire ça simple pour vous dire ce
que je pense est-ce que c'est moral non
ça ne l'est pas c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que c'est interdit est-ce que la
situation est complexe à cause de la
mondialisation oui aujourd'hui il y a
des pays qui l'acceptent et donc c'est
pas compliqué de prendre l'avion d'aller
quelque part de faire une GPA et de
revenir d'accord alors à ce moment là on
va dire quoi il y a deux solutions soit
on dit ah bah de toute façon c'est la
mondialisation donc on fait ce qu'on
veut et donc les lois françaises n'ont
plus l'intérêt alors vous dites pas ça
moi je dis pas ça et c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement en vrai ou soit on dit bah
nous en France non c'est pas comme ça
nous on accepte pas la GPA donc non
pénalise la GPA et nous on ne veut pas
voilà alors la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour qu'il nous
auditeurs comprennent c'est les dans le
fonctionnement du droit européen j'ai
pas m'étendre ici elle a fait elle a
sanctionné qu'est-ce que doit faire donc
la France et le président de la
République je vous rappelle c'était
engagé sur ce sujet à apprendre des
initiatives juridiques pour qu'enfin ça
soit dans les faits et pas uniquement
dans les principes interdits en France
la GPA il devait donc prendre une
initiative législative il ne la prennent
pas alors après bien sûr naturellement
un tribunal celui de Nantes sur la base
de ce qu'a dit la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dit ah ben non c'est
pas possible
votre question c'est que faire de ces
enfants arrêtons l'hypie les enfants ils
sont pas hors-sol qu'est-ce que la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme veut
faire elle veut transcrire dans l'état
civil c'est à dire que les parents qui
auraient fait des GPA à l'étranger
considèrent que en gros on mettrait dans
leur état civil que c'est voilà né de
Monsieur et de Madame voilà c'est pas ça
la réalité si on fait ça ça veut dire
qu'on autorise la GPA c'est ce qu'on
définitive le gouvernement fait par
hypocrisie ne rien faire c'est légaliser
la GPA c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire nous on prendra j'en suis certain
et ça ils sont tous d'accord à l'UMP sur
le sujet un engagement très clair devant
les français en 2017 pour que en France
la GPA qui est une horreur c'est la
marchandisation du corps de la femme ça
soit interdit pas dans les mots mais
dans les actes en parler un petit peu de
votre partie on est toujours mardi il y
avait un bureau politique un bureau
national et on a décidé d'élargir un
petit peu ce bureau à 115 membres si je
me trompe pas on est allé à devant ce
bureau et on a écouté Jean-Pierre
Raffarin juste à la sortir regardez je
pense quand même que tout ceci est
gouverné avec une certaine autorité et
que les uns et les autres on les
capacités à la fois s'exprimer mais en
même temps harmoniser nos débats là le
consensus prouve qu'on peut être
nombreux mais à condition qu'il y ait
beaucoup de préparation parce que le
résultat d'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de discussions et au
fond le respect des uns et des autres
certains ont parlé d'armée mexicaine 115
on a surtout l'impression que tout
change même le nom mais que rien ne
change en fait non mais attendez de quoi
parle-t-on on est depuis deux ans dans
l'opposition on a eu deux ans
je vous dis juste il y a le moment venu
une primaire qui désignera celle de
celui qui portera nos couleurs c'est pas
un bureau politique qui va désigner
c'est tous les Français qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs de la
droite et du centre qui viendront
choisir leur candidats après on verra
bien qu'il sera candidat Alain Juppé
François Fillon on dit qu'il le seront
Nicolas pas dit Bruno Le Maire ne l'a
pas encore dit c'est pas parce qu'on a
dit qu'on le serait qu'on le sera
vraiment le moment venu et c'est pas
parce qu'on a pas encore dit qu'on
allait l'être qu'on ne le saura pas et
c'est demain il faut essayer de
comprendre
la République c'est un joli nom on a
tellement entendu on a tellement entendu
la gauche et l'UMP en disant
vous n'êtes pas républicain vous pourrez
pour la bonne question vous n'êtes pas
républicain du côté et que la droite
républicaine soit tellement républicaine
qu'elle s'appelle les républicains ça
devrait réjouir les choses regardez son
âge 54% des sympathisants UMP pour faire
un résumé son favorable à ce changement
de nom c'est pas une grosse autorité
c'est même un petit c'est assez faible
on peut dire mais je prends ce sondage
bien sûr mais je voulais je vous donne
le fond de ma pensée c'est pas
l'essentiel de ce que la droite doit
faire après la droite c'est notre
culture on a changé de nom 10 fois nous
on voilà Nicolas Sarkozy avait dit qu'il
changerait non il propose un nom c'est
un joli nom moi ça me pose pas de
problème je soutiendrai cette démarche
je vous dis juste c'est pas l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est qu'on soit rassemblé
c'est qu'on gère les compétitions
individuelles et si surtout on ne joue
pas sur une alternance naturelle parce
que la gauche aura échoué en 2017 dans
la gestion du pays la droite va gagner
automatiquement non moi je ne veux pas
ça c'est déterminisme est terrible ce
que je veux c'est que mon parti et que
le candidat qui sortira des primaires il
apporte enfin les solutions que la
France n'a pas suffisamment rencontré
depuis 30 ans on va revenir sur les
primaires tout à l'heure je vous propose
de parler de la gauche puisque mercredi
Claude barthelen se montre bien entouré
Claude Barcelone président de
l'Assemblée nationale et tout nouveau
candidat à la présidence de la région
Île-de-France il est apparu aux côtés
des élus socialistes d'Île-de-France les
socialistes rassemblés mais pas toute la
gauche les communistes et les vers vont
visiblement faire bande à part Thierry
solaire pas d'union de la gauche en vue
et comment ça va se passer à droite
notamment avec l'UDI pour ces régionales
en Île-de-France vous êtes le
porte-parole de la campagne de Valérie
Pécresse alors d'abord tu vas les
répécresse nous on s'est rassemblé
depuis longtemps derrière Valérie parce
que Valérie elle a pris pas des
orientations dans tous les sens elle se
consacre à cette région Île-de-France
qui est depuis 17 ans géré par la gauche
le bilan est catastrophique c'est pas
moi qui dit c'est la gauche elle-même
c'est la première fois d'ailleurs et je
trouve que vous devriez regarder ça avec
intérêt que la gauche constatant qu'elle
a un mauvais bilan change son Président
je serai François Hollande je
m'inquiéterais de la conséquence que ça
peut avoir pour 2017 qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont pris ils ont choisi Claude Barcelone
bon écoutez Claude Barcelone il est
comptable d'un triple bilan celui de la
gestion sociale de la région je vous
rappelle qu'il a été élu avec Jean-Paul
Huchon donc il est comptable
dans la région de France il était
conseiller régional avec Jean-Paul
Huchon il a été président du Conseil
général de la Seine-Saint-Denis si les
France il y a envie d'avoir une gestion
de l'Île-de-France comme celle qui a été
celle de la Seine-Saint-Denis par
Monsieur Bartolone
et puis enfin il est comptablement
Claude Barcelone du bilan de Manuel
Valls et de François Hollande depuis 3
ans il est l'année principaux leaders de
la majorité c'est lui qui a fait voter
les lois qui ont arrêté les crédits sur
l'apprentissage des 2012 c'est lui qui a
fait voter toutes les lois qui ont
augmenté la fiscalité dans des telles
proportions depuis 3 ans vous voyez le
changement il est vraiment attendu par
les Franciliens on l'a vu aux
municipales on l'a vu au départementale
et je suis certain que vous verrez on le
verra au moment des élections du mois de
décembre prochain votre question par
rapport à l'UDI nous on travaille avec
l'idée toujours ce ne sont nos
partenaire naturel on travaille avec eux
dans les mairies on travaille avec eux
dans les départements quand la droite
est au pouvoir elle travaille avec eux
au gouvernement et donc Valérie Pécresse
et et Chantal Jouanno travaille en
parfaite cohérence moi j'ai bon espoir
qu'on arrive à faire une liste unique je
pense que ce qu'attendent les
Franciliens parce que au fond ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un vrai changement et puis
surtout ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas que
la droite remplace la gauche ce qu'ils
veulent c'est enfin avoir quelqu'un qui
répare toutes les erreurs depuis 30 ans
et vous avez vu les trains vous demandez
tout de suite non plus tard très bien ça
se passe très bien vous verrez il y a
aucun problème et on travaille tous
ensemble
toutes les raisons que ça se termine
très bien et surtout le plus important
je vous dis c'est qu'on arrive enfin à
régler les problèmes que notre région
connaît vous avez vu les les centaines
de kilomètres de bouchons la pollution
voilà et la thématique de la gauche qui
consiste à dire nous on est là pour
enlever les inégalités mais regardez au
bout de 17 ans de gestion de gauche le
niveau inégalitaire de cette région la
Seine-Saint-Denis elle concentre tous
les mots ça fait 17 ans
vous avez trouvé aussi votre votre cible
la gestion de la personne vous avez donc
le Barcelone on a bien compris que
c'était la cible numéro on va faire un
petit crochet par le Sénat s'il vous
plaît bien on a examiné en commission la
loi sur le renseignement
cette loi a été votée à la somme
nationale elle arrivera début juin dans
l'hémicyclo c'est non mais elle a été
étudiée en commission les sénateurs
représentés leur proposition et la
droite peut modifier encore une fois ce
texte les détails avec Cécile c'est que
revue et corrigée entre les mains des
sénateurs en commission des lois au
Sénat le texte renseignement a subi
quelques retouches 145 amendements pour
mieux garantir le respect de la vie
privée mais aussi mieux contrôler des
techniques de renseignement intrusives
c'était donc une sorte de jungle
législative nous y mettons de l'ordre
pour en faire non pas un jardin à la
française mais un système permettant
d'assurer à la fois la protection des
citoyens et des intérêts fondamentaux du
pays face aux risques de crime de délit
d'actes terrorisme mais aussi la
protection de leur vie privée et de leur
liberté fondamentale une balise sur une
voiture une mise sur écoute ou encore la
captation d'information sur ordinateur
les sénateurs proposent de limiter le
recours à ces techniques mais aussi de
réduire les délais de conservation de
données collectées de quatre mois il
passerait à deux mois
votre propositions surveiller davantage
les services de renseignement en
renforçant les pouvoirs de la cnctr
l'autorité qui les contrôle le
gouvernement compte également proposé
des modifications au texte nous allons
prendre des amendements par exemple pour
vraiment préciser que les techniques qui
ont fait le plus débats sont des
techniques de ciblage et non pas de
surveillance massive contrairement à ce
que j'ai entendu depuis des semaines ça
ne correspond pas à la réalité et pour
donner toute garantie sur ce point nous
allons prendre des amendements qui
montrent bien que les principales
activités sont centrées sur la lutte
antiterroriste le projet de loi arrivera
en séance le 4 juin prochain
je vais vous poser les questions sur le
renseignement dans quelques secondes le
temps de vous présenter Jim Jared du
scan notre partenaire du Figaro qui est
avec nous qui vous interrogera dans
quelques secondes revenons sur la loi
sur le renseignement vous n'avez pas
voté cette loi à l'Assemblée nationale
pourquoi d'abord parce que si c'était
une loi exclusivement sur le
renseignement qui avait eu pour vocation
de donner un cadre légal à des activités
parfois illégales que les services de
renseignement mettent en œuvre depuis
des années j'aurais voté pour mais on
élargit les champs à peu près tout
deuxièmement on nous présente cette loi
comme à l'Alfa le Mégane de la lutte
antiterroriste est-ce que cette loi si
elle avait existé aurait permis d'éviter
la ferme Ahmed Merah qui était suivie
par les services de renseignement pas
suffisamment en tout cas il l'avait été
il n'était plus au moment où il a bien
sûr procédé à son attentat est-ce que
les frères kouaching avait été suivis
par les services de renseignement cette
loi aurait pu nous éviter à la faire du
mois de janvier non je ne le crois pas
moi ce que je crois que vous êtes en
train de dire c'est que cette loi ne
sert pas forcément à grand chose à
l'heure actuelle et d'être déjà obsolète
parce que je crois c'est qu'il faut que
l'État se donne des et qu'à force de
vouloir mettre de l'État partout souvent
l'État est une contrainte dans la vie
économique notamment l'état est
inefficace à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques publiques et si vous voulez
avoir des résultats sur ces sujets là il
faut mettre le moyen en terme budgétaire
en termes d'effectif plus
poursuivre plus de personnes on
travaille ce sujet en France que c'est
un parent pauvre en France
et quand on voit quand on compare
notamment avec nos voisins allemands et
anglais on voit qu'en France on a une
culture de défiance en vrai à l'endroit
des services de renseignement on aura
pas donné suffisamment de moyens et on
n'aura pas donné un cadre législatif
solide pour eux-mêmes d'ailleurs pardon
pourquoi un agent de la DGSE devrait
faire des choses en dehors du droit il
se met en risque potentiel personnel et
ce n'est pas admissible qu'un agent de
la fonction publique soit dans cette
situation la loi là elle n'a pas apporté
ses réponses là elle était trop large
elle vise pourtant encadrer l'activité
de la Duse de la
dgsibles voilà mais elle est beaucoup
trop large et deuxièmement quand vous
voyez des juges antiterroriste quand
vous voyez le défenseur des droits quand
vous voyez les deux syndicats principaux
syndicats la magistrature quand vous
voyez des agents de ses services et
qu'il vous disent que c'est pas ça dont
ils ont besoin eux-mêmes vous finissez
par vous dire qu'il y a quand même un
petit sujet
Thierry solaire on va reparler de
politique puisque c'est l'heure de
passer à la loupe du scan avec notre
partenaire Jim Jara c'est du Figaro
bonjour
on va parler un peu de Bruno Le Maire
parce qu'il faut dire que c'était quand
même un peu la semaine Bruno Le Maire
cette semaine tribune contre la réforme
du collège signé par la quasi totalité
des parlementaires UMP projet présenté
dans Libération toujours sur le collège
débat face à Najat Vallaud-Belkacem bon
sans conteste Bruno Le Maire il a il a
vraiment marqué des points cette semaine
on a eu l'impression que l'UMP et un
petit retard d'allumage on se pose la
question qu'est-ce qui manque encore à
Bruno Le Maire pour qu'il se déclare
candidat à la primaire de 2016 d'abord
il a sur le sujet de l'éducation
clairement pris le leadership à droite
sur ces sujets moi je m'en réjouis de la
bonne le maire pour notre famille
politique et pour le pays parce qu'il
faudra l'alternance en 2017 les Français
à la tendance j'en suis certain et donc
il faudra que le sujet de l'éducation ne
soit pas la dernière eau du carrosse et
Bruno Le Maire il a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet il a été un opposant précis
à la réforme plus que Nicolas Sarkozy
par exemple qui me demandait pas une
échelle de valeur en tout cas Bruno il a
énormément travaillé sur ce sujet et il
a aujourd'hui un projet qui n'est pas
ficelé à 100% il a des modifications
encore mais en tout cas voilà c'est il a
un projet différent celui du
gouvernement et ça c'est bien vu
d'ailleurs hier dans l'émission
qu'est-ce qui lui manque encore pour se
déclarer à la primaire je pense que
c'est pas une décision qu'on prend la
légère il continue de travailler déjà
prise je pense je sais qu'il travaille
et que son objectif c'est d'être
candidat à la primaire et je sais qu'il
prendra ses décisions le moment venu en
fonction de plein de paramètres on ne
prend pas cette décision à la légère je
vais renverser la question qu'est-ce qui
pourrait empêcher Bruno Le Maire ne pas
être candidat à la primaire est-ce qu'il
est candidat à la primaire je pense
qu'il le sera ça sera pour la gagner et
il ne sera pas candidat à la primaire
simplement pour faire comme on a vu à
gauche un candidat faire un score 5 %
son objectif c'est d'avoir un projet
cohérent pour que le pays se redresse on
est dans un pays qui depuis 30 ou 40 ans
on a on a plein de merveilles en France
on est souvent parce qu'on gère le
déclin c'est ça que les Français vivent
au quotidien on a l'impression qu'on
accompagne le déclin que parfois on
accompagne de gauche qu'on accompagne de
droite mais qu'on accompagne un déclin
parce que les Français veulent c'est
qu'on se redresse pour ça il faut avoir
un projet cohérent et il se déclara
candidat quand il aura la plénitude
on verra alors vous êtes un soutien
conditionnel de Bruno Le Maire on l'a
bien compris mais pas seulement ce qu'on
sait moi c'est que vous faisiez partie
de l'équipe web de Nicolas Sarkozy en
2007 ça remonte un peu vous allez donc
pouvoir commenter avec nous le chat de
Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il a réalisé c'était
il y a toupie une semaine sur Twitter
alors ça a suscité pas mal de
commentaires parfois un peu négatif le
président de l'UMP il a parlé de du PSG
il a parlé de série télé il a parlé de
ses animaux de compagnie de Cyril
Hanouna au final assez peu de politique
est-ce que c'était la bonne stratégie de
communication de Nicolas Sarkozy sur
Twitter je sais pas moi à l'époque où je
m'occupais de la campagne de 2007 sur ça
existait pas Twitter non non donc je
sais pas la bonne stratégie en tout cas
moi je trouve ça plutôt sympa de trouver
régulièrement des hommes politiques vous
voyez vous avez vu aux États-Unis
l'actuel président des États-Unis et
tous ces prédécesseurs à l'occasion du
départ d'un journaliste très connu se
mettre en scène écouter un peu de
simplicité un peu de proximité et que à
l'occasion de Twitter d'un film Twitter
on arrive à discuter comme ça c'est
plutôt bien après bien sûr Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est une marque il a été
président de la République il y a des
gens des gens qui réagissent ils
arrivent et tout mais au fond qu'est-ce
qui compte ce qui compte c'est que
Nicolas Sarkozy qui est revenu à la tête
de l'UMP il fasse tourner bien l'UMP et
franchement moi qui suis bravo Bruno Le
Maire je vous le dis ça marche vraiment
vraiment bien deuxièmement le moment
venu lui-même il leur apprend sa
décision est-ce qu'il est candidat ou
pas à la primaire je me doute j'ai le
sentiment qu'il est revenu dans la vie
politique pour être candidat à la
primaire mais pour tout le monde même
pour Nicolas Sarkozy prendre cette
décision là ça se prend pas la légère
Nicolas Sarkozy il a été chef d'État
s'il est candidat à la primaire c'est
qu'il sentira qu'il a un projet et qui
peut gagner cette primaire et surtout
l'élection présidentielle derrière merci
beaucoup Jim on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
on va reparler des primaires c'est le
plus de l'hebdo
vous êtes en charge des primaires pour
la droite qui auront lieu en 2016 c'est
une première pour votre camp c'est un
modèle qui vient des États-Unis qui a
été utilisé par la gauche depuis 2006
c'est l'histoire des primaires qu'on
vous propose c'est vu et corrigé par
Simon barbares c'était une première dans
la vie politique française en octobre
2006 les chaînes parlementaires
diffusaient les débats des primaires
socialistes l'idée vient des États-Unis
où l'organisation des primaires figure
dans les règles internes des parties
républicains et démocrates mais voilà la
France de la Cinquième République ce
n'est pas l'Amérique be partit en France
la tradition républicaine veut que le
chef de l'État soit l'arbitre suprême
issu d'une relation particulière avec le
peuple et non l'homme ou la femme d'un
camp que penser alors de cette mise en
scène de la confrontation entre alliés
politiques ou les rivalités
individuelles sont exacerbées et le
futur candidat abîmé comme le déplore
douloureusement encore aujourd'hui
Ségolène Royal et quand vous regardez la
campagne très peu on dit du bien de moi
très très peu et enfin s'il y avait un
candidat tous les jours il y avait 15
personnes qui disaient du bien du
candidat donc à partir de là c'était
quand même très difficile car dans une
primaire si chacun prend la parole à
tour de rôle les désaccords les
divisions ou même les attaques
personnelles semblent inévitables et
durant la campagne des primaires
socialistes de 2011 Martin Aubry n'avait
pas mâché ses mots à l'encontre de
François Hollande ma grand-mère disait
quand c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un loup
voilà donc j'ai essayé de mettre le
doigt sur certains de ces loups hier
soir je suis une palades la gauche
sectaire j'avais pas aimé qu'il reprenne
le terme de la droite pour la CMU pour
les 35 heures non moi je suis une gauche
forte en 2016 c'est l'UMP qui cessera
pour la première fois aux primaires un
choix inédit mais pour quel motif un
signe de modernité dont le
fonctionnement du parti ou l'absence
d'un candidat naturel et légitime dans
un parti miner par les rivalités
personnelles la compétition interne
pourrait laisser des traces à la
primaire c'est bien mais ça peut laisser
des traces ça peut être violent pour la
famille il y a plein de qualité de
défauts ou primaires en tout cas moi ce
que je peux vous dire pour la droite
française c'est que il y a un défaut
qu'on pourra pas reproduire c'est
d'avoir deux candidats de notre famille
politique au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est ça le tradition
Chirac balade en 95 et avant c'était
rpdf c'était Giscard Chirac si on fait
ça on y sera même pas au second tour
parce que les Français attendent c'est
surtout que la droite apporte les bonnes
solutions et aussi qu'on soit rassemblés
et la primaire ça sera moi je n'ose pas
l'homme providentiel et la primaire
l'homme providentiel il sortira la
primaire et vous êtes prêts vous êtes
prêts pour cette primaire et l'état
d'esprit est prêt moi je trouve je veux
dire après les guerres immenses qu'on a
connu pendant deux ans je trouve qu'au
contraire cette primaire qui est
maintenant actée on connaît son
calendrier ça sera les 20 et 27 novembre
2016 on connaît les modalités maintenant
je dois travailler avec tout le groupe à
la mise en oeuvre opérationnelle c'est
une règle du jeu et la règle du jeu ça
gère les compétitions c'est beaucoup
mieux que que le meilleur gagne et puis
c'est le plus village général et puis
vous ouvrez est-ce que vous souhaitez
que
puis cette candidat cette primaire en
tout cas l'organisation qu'on a mis en
oeuvre permet à François Bayrou s'il se
reconnaît dans les valeurs de la droite
et du centre et s'il est un opposant il
souhaite l'alternance à François
Hollande d'être candidats
à titre personnel j'entends ce que dit
François Bayrou il a appelé à voter pour
François Hollande la dernière fois et il
a déclaré que s'il avait été
parlementaire récemment au moment du
49-3 il n'aurait pas voté la censure
donc je ne suis pas certain qu'alors où
on parle François Bayrou soit dans une
logique d'alternance à François Hollande
mais c'est à lui le dire moi je n'ai pas
de jugement de valeur apportée je vous
dis juste nous c'est les bras sont
grandes ouverts et nos partenaires
notamment ceux de l'UDI ils sont bien
sûr les bienvenus pour venir travailler
avec nous dans cette primaire pour
revenir qu'on choisit
tout à l'heure pour vous parler des
régionales en Île-de-France quand on
travaille ensemble et que ça marche bien
et que les électeurs attendent ça avec
les résultats sont au rendez-vous ça
marche dans les mairies ça marche dans
les départements ça marche dans les
régions pour le pays qui peuvent qui se
sont déjà engagés
énormément ensemble au Parlement et puis
Nicolas Sarkozy donc président de l'UMP
et Jean-Christophe Lagarde se voit très
régulièrement je sais que ce sujet est
plus qu'abordé donc vous êtes convaincu
que cette culture quand même assez
américaine peut prendre en France et
dans votre dans votre partie bien sûr
parce qu'on est au 21e siècle et je
trouve qu'on a toujours intérêt à
élargir le socle de ceux qui décident
par rapport à le resserrer et le
refermer ça pourrait concilier les
Français avec la politique
surtout les Français avec la politique
c'est que la politique apporte des
résultats et aujourd'hui la défiance ou
les aspirations elle vient elle se
nourrit du fait qu'il y a pas
suffisamment de résultats à gauche comme
à droite dans les politiques publiques
entre ce qu'on annonce et ce qu'on fait
il y a trop de décalage c'est pour ça
que moi je vous dis en 2017 le vrai défi
de la droite c'est celui-là c'est de
redresser le pays de s'engager pas sur
300 000 choses et de tenir le revenu les
hôtels vous ferez le même modèle que ce
qu'a fait le Parti socialiste en 2012 où
est-ce qu'il y aura nouveauté vous allez
tout changer tout révolutionner il y a
une différence d'abord la campagne sera
un petit peu plus longue il l'avait fait
en octobre
ça sera en novembre
eux ils permettaient à beaucoup beaucoup
de candidats de venir ce qui permettait
à chacun d'avoir à faire trois quatre
cinq pour cent pour être ministre nous
c'est solide et on viendra pas pour
facilement dans la primaire et puis
enfin le parti au lendemain de la
primaire alors que François Hollande
avait gagné et Martine Aubry elle est
retournée gérer le PS nous c'est celui
qui gagnera la primaire qui qui décidera
du fonctionnement de l'UMP pour les
législatives et la planète donc c'est
clair très bien bah merci Thierry
solaire savoir commenter l'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine à tous